こんにちは今日はティ e カードですけども
日本語で polling pdus e フラーレンッティマーレ a
どうしてあのー
いろんな人がですね
外国語ですね view 長に話せるようになられるでしょうか
まぁ日本の場合はですね外国語を勉強している人が大部分が英語を勉強してますよね
もちろん巻9号とか中国語とかスペイン具をフランス語に対してね
興味のある人もいるけれども音
野間大部分が今英語を勉強してますがそのうちですねほんとに流暢にね
英語を話せるようになる人が極めて少ないです
日本私が毎度
日本に来ましたですね本屋さんいきますともう英語の勉強に関する法案までたくさん
ありますね
といくん
とかね
色々あるんですけれども結局はあの流暢に話せる英語を話せる日本人が極めて少ない
です
同市でしょうかまああのそれは日本人が英語を勉強するにだけじゃなくてどんな人でも
です願い国防 benq ルースを勉強するときにですね
それをですねやった経験がない
その自分がねその一つの言葉しか話せない人間からですね
もう一つの外部を柳絮にその話せるようにそのなったあぁそういう変化が起こってない
人にはですね
そういうケーキがないからですね実際にその成功する
ゆうちょになる級地震
がないというのが非常に大きな原因です
言葉の勉強に関しましてはして私いつもようには一番大事な要素が蜜が一つは勉強して
いる人の態度
この言葉ラスキーがどうか本当に勉強さの習いたいかですね
それからその新しい言葉ですねそのうちに対処し抵抗しているかどうかですね
自信あるかどうかですねそういう心理的な方が理論台数がまたも一番大事なんですよ
その先生とか学校とか
何
比べてもですねまず対応
第2話時間その言葉を勉強するのですね時間かかろう
児童はん
代表の勉強しますけれども時間かかるそれ第3番目ばですね
やはりその注意深くその何がこの言葉で起こっているかどういうふうに本当に発音され
ているかですね
それを注意しないといけませんで
ジャソン浴す3つの要素の中ですねまあみんないつもすぐは春朝の大老の
もう重要視ですね
モチベーションですよね本当にやりたいと
じゃあウォッチ米社がなければもちろんその成功しまぁそりゃしないそれはもう誰でも
わかりますけれども僕のあってる人でね
日本人だけじゃなくてですね非常に勉強したいとも初々しいがあるけれども
生保しないなぜでしょうかなぜでしょうか
そこにはですねやはりその自信というか経験
やったことないからその他分
なりえないと
そういう悲観的なですね心理が非常に働いたと思うんですよ
例えば山登りの場合はねその4位
その
山頂が毒にバンカー
えその山頂までに上るようなイメージがね
ない糸ですねー
非常に僕はも近しいと思いますそれと同じようにですね
実際にビュー長になったことないからだから山頂までイメージがないからですね
逆に言葉の勉強のいろんなフラストレーションがたまるわけです
で言葉の勉強がやはり理恵
それがですねー
+ tc が多いです
はっきりましてね
勉強した例えば辞書調べたらエ
その新しい単語の意味を調べたらすぐ忘れます
同じ鋳物をな小さなのテキスト何回聞いても同じところは1問ありましたとか
ある程度も覚えがあってもですね自分が
水塩ですねやはり伝えたいときにですねうまく
話しできませんと
例えばそのいろんな人と綿棒国語の人たちと混ぜて飲みに行った場合ですね
どうしてもこの
この回はわかりましたとかいろいろありますよ
うずらステーション
アルトあるあるいはですね何かを勉強したためにですね
例えば私まあ分とのるーるー
読んで
第部門わかりませんけども分かってもですね
覚えられないとか
は知られるとか
ただして使えませんとかあるいは号医療ですね
見て
連休して
えそれでもまわしてみましたね
そういうふぁーすべきが確かに多いですそれ誰でもそうです
私も同じです彼等が14ヶ国語を勉強した経緯があります
13覚悟5カ国語まあ
程度が違いますけれども払わせますはいそれでも
はされます覚えませんん
分かりません
これが中年中年にある
だけどもあの徐々に続きますとね
私の経験からすると続ければ最終的には
政府しましたいう自信ある
通して自信あるカプリ行ったことがあったらそれ知ってます
そういうフラステイ者があるにしてもですね
最終的には続けばそういう刺激を
頭脳に与えればだんだんど
頭脳がねなれますだから言葉の勉強というのはそれを一つの知識覚えるというよりも
これはもうなれる
なれなれ
そういうようなものなんですよだからそれを信じれば別にそのフラストレーションが
問題
まあそれでもフラストレーションはあるけれどももう一つ大切な
なのはですね言葉を勉強するときにその楽しいことをやられてきました
私の場合はですね
文法に関するいろんな
c 注文とカードビールとかそれ絶対ありません
好きじゃないです好きじゃないから僕は効果的じゃないと思っています
それよりも
ないや
興味のあるもの
聞いたり読んだいわゆる多読多聴ですね
私が面白いともテキストを読んだり聞いたりはたちが好きな声の人のええええの何でも
いいでしょ
日本語ロシア路を行きマスターだからできるだけ自分が楽しいと思っている
その勉強方法で勉強しています
ショーしますともうディベーションを1できます
それから時間も十分な時間をその
言葉と
園生
何ですか使えますよね
だから楽しいことをやらないといけませんある人は
でバー貫石峰の漢方を勉強するために韓国のメロドラマおきたいと
日本語勉強人たちがですねええ
例えばアニメのたびにとか
まあいろいろそういうのがあるわけですよだから楽しく楽しくじゃないといけないと
それが非常に大事と
でやるあり経度文法のルートかそういうもの
3見る日所があるけれども見てから勉強してからそれでは覚えるかというとそうじゃ
ないんですよ
それを見てまた色々0な楽しい勉強の仕方も映画を言ったり
絵本を読んだり流木を聞いたりして
その時に出来るだけその
注意してね
文法の本でいたアーちゃんたくさん売られてるとも web
可能性は
ないんだけどもいくつかそういうルールが
登りましたら年でまた聞いたあーなるほど行ったとかあるいはそれだけたくさん聞い
たり読んだりした後でですね
文法の部分を見るとああなるほど
いうのがね徐々に徐々に慣れてくる
勉強したから先生が教えましたからそれじゃあできるかとそういうことは絶対ないです
から
それはどんなにた人でもそれはないです
であのー者以後ですねやはり僕は今
67歳ですよね a
最近
にな23年でも
ろしてまず主語はあーん
5年前から始めましたけれどもま着後とか路面宿とか今観光とか
だからそりゃ年齢とは関係なし
それからあのどんな国の人でもね僕のしてる日本人9中国人労働者で流暢にですね他の
言葉です
のいわゆる欧米人でもね大部分がにも一定で日本語を話せませんけれども本当に日本語
を勉強したい人であれば欧米人でも
勉強できます
日本人でも
中国粥語でもフランス語でも英語でも勉強できます
年齢とは関係なしだからそれをやったことのない人にはねそういう経験のない人には
ですねやはり
信じるじゃないんですよ
一旦そういう
その1本目の山をね登りましたがその3畳まで届いたらね
ついたらね
えええ
自分がそれができると
いう風になったらねその頭ですね
次の山次の山次の言葉それはやりやすくなるわけですよ
自分にとってん
ここ的な勉強方法もだんだんとそういう技術ができるし自信もついてくるし
だけども大部分の人たちはねそこまでなってないわけですよ
だからそういう人たちに対してはねやはり
青黒必ず成功しますそれを信じていただいてほしいですよね
必ず成功しますそれなりに続かないといけません
そして楽しく勉強しないといけませんそしてそういうフラストレーションをですね
忘れましたもわからなかったそれはねえ関係ないです
それよりも時間
を15日買って続ければ必ず成功します
で成功すればですねやはりあの
第二の言葉をねまあ色である栄養は15なる中国をですね
第二の言葉で流暢にその国の人間とあります
第3国の人間といろんなコミュニケーションができるとですね
いいかに楽しいことだというのを本当にこれ感じるわけです
4そうなったらやはりやりたいと
でやり日本の前はマーシーいえば島国で1億に3000万人が住んでいる
産卵英語勉強する必要あるかというような信念の人達も多いと思うんですがそれも
やはり
やったことないから総合であってですね year
まず
第一ね
外国をそれ英語なら英語
処理は必ずできると指示で頑張ってくださいそれでは何か具体的なご質問でもあれば
ぜひあの
僕のこちら youtube の茶のでも日本語でもいいから
質問
すれば私ができるだけあのー
ございますそれじゃあ皆さんさようなら